[Musique]
petit fruit
oui oui petits fruits d'origine
méditerranéenne la piste hd parti de la
cuisine de plusieurs pays arabes dont la
syrie à la pâtisserie maroussi c'est le
produit vedette
ça fait depuis plusieurs siècles que les
syriens utilise la pistache dans tous
leurs desserts dont on leur met pas ce
que ça représente pour vraiment la vie
la fraîcheur la bonne qualité à notre
homme cousy son équipe préparent chaque
jour près d'une dizaine de pâtisseries
dans lesquels on utilise les pistaches
vous avez ici les biscuits qu'on appelle
balazé avec la pistache on a essayé le
bol main pharcyde pistache entière en
raison de la guerre en syrie les
pistaches d'alep ne sont plus
disponibles cela ici est de la turquie
est ici en un les pistaches durant la
grande différence entre les deux sorte
qu'on utilise c'est vraiment la couleur
on retrouve plus de pistaches iranienne
sur le marché parce qu'elles sont
importés en mars la meilleure et la
turque selon moi mais elle est plus rare
c'est pourquoi nous l'utilisons surtout
comme garniture et dans les brumes à ils
et ballerines ou vous trouvez la
pistache à l'intérieur et saupoudré par
dessous
on a les turcs qui sont plus fines est
là qui ont un très bon goût et il ya une
petite distinction de saveur 1 il est un
peu plus sucré disons que l'autre gbc à
laval on est porte les pistaches de
l'est turquie mais aussi de la
californie sont légalistes un virage et
californie les produits qui viennent des
états unis sont un peu différents de
ceux qui viennent du moyen orient
car à l'origine le pistache il est
originaire il ya plus de 5000 ans de la
de l'asie et du moyen orient
[Musique]
ça ne fait que deux cents ans que
l'amérique du nord a reçu les premières
rares de pistaches mais c'est devenu
très populaire aujourd'hui le plus grand
réducteur si on peut dire comme ça de
pistaches au monde sont les états unis
dans la région de réformer certainement
il ya une petite différence entre la
qualité de californie qui est devenu
plus commerciales et celles qui viennent
du moyen orient qui est plus pour le
pour le consommateur qui a un plaisir
mediterrania les pistaches de la
californie sont en général plus grosse
que celle de l'est turquie qui plus
effilé et plus foncée
le premier tueur et les deux excellentes
qualités qui fait une production assez
importante et qui en ce moment grand la
place de l'iran et de la syrie
en amérique du nord le prix assez
raisonnable à peu près similaires comme
les cachots où comme les amendes
on peut trouver sur le marché des
pistaches nature avec ou sans ical et
comme pour les amendes par exemple elles
peuvent être rôti et ses amis
quand on fait le rôtissage on ajoute
l'assaisonnement
indépendamment du client eh bien nous
avons huit variétés différentes
d'assaisonnement comment on conserve les
pistaches pour garder le plus longtemps
parce dans un endroit sec et froid
il aura une garantie et de vie d'à peu
près six mois
une portion de pistage de 40 g contient
environ 6 g de protéines soit
l'équivalent de 1,9 cuit dur c'est donc
une aliments est intéressant du point de
vue nutritionnel
ça a beaucoup de vitamines beaucoup de
protéines et puis ça vraiment bien fait
nutritive la pistache et très populaire
dans la crème glacée et on peut
l'ajouter à plusieurs recettes dans des
terrines ou du tajine par exemple mais
son emploi le plus fréquent reste bien
sûr en pâtisserie de ce fait pour anas
il n'y a rien comme le burma pour le
satisfaire
ils aiment beaucoup leur ment en
particulier parce qu'il sent le goût de
la pistache à l'intérieur il aime
vraiment beaucoup la pistache et il aime
quand ces dépistages entier
si vous achetez les pistaches en mechal
choisissez les plus blanches et les plus
ouverte possible 2 signe de fraîcheur